the Targaryen dynasty United the Seven
Kingdoms and lasted nearly three
centuries it was a dynasty forged in
fire sealed in blood and destroyed by
rebellion
the Targaryen Tsar blood of the dragon
descended from the nobility of ancient
Valyria a once mighty empire in the east
when the cataclysmic doom laid waste of
Valyria and its people the Targaryen
survived having settled on the island
fortress of Dragonstone years before
they remained there for essentially
until the rise of Aegon the conquerer
instead of attempting to reclaim the
eastern lands of his ancestors Aegon
sailed west for the Seven Kingdoms his
sisters Visenya and Ramos at his side to
keep the bloodlines pure Aegon continued
the custom of his Valyrian ancestors and
took both of his sisters two wife
together they came ashore on the eastern
coast of Westeros their blazing a dragon
with three heads representing Aegon and
his sister wives their words fire and
blood while their host was small in
comparison to the armies of Westeros
that awaited them Aegon and his sisters
had a secret weapon the last of the
dragons
he conquered every Kingdom save dawn
which eventually bowed to daguerreian
rule a century later he had the swords
of his enemies melted down by the fiery
breath of his dragon balerion the black
dread and forged into the iron throne
the capital city of King's Landing was
built on the eastern coast where Aegon
and his sisters first came ashore and
Aegon ordered the construction of a
royal castle on its highest hill the red
keep for 300 years the Targaryen dynasty
stayed strong in the face of rebellion
civil war and plague but the line of
Dragon Kings was broken when my father
Aerys Targaryen the second of his name
was overthrown in rebellion
my father was betrayed and slaughtered
by ser Jaime Lannister a member of his
own Kingsguard his son and heir my
brother Rhaegar perished on the field of
battle at the hands of Robert Baratheon
who claimed the iron throne for himself
and so today the only surviving members
of the story Targaryen dynasty and
myself Prince Viserys rightful king of
the Andals and ruler of the Seven
Kingdoms and my sister Daenerys we were
spirited away to the Free Cities of the
East by loyalists here we have lived in
exile ever since dreaming of a day when
we will cross the Narrow Sea and take
back my father's home
you